[Musique]
urbaine mais l'écart dépend des
différents types d'infractions des
différents types de délits par exemple
elle est cambriolages en 2022 dans
l'habitat rural à trait à disperser que
vous voyez en vert sur notre infographie
et bien il y a eu plus de trois
cambriolages pour 1000 habitants c'est
un peu plus dans les bourses ruraux
représentés en bleu 4,4 cambriolages
pour 1000 habitants et c'est un taux qui
est de plus de deux fois supérieur dans
les grands centres urbains en rouge
7,6 cambriolages pour 1000 habitants
même écart même proportion concernant
les vols de véhicules en 2022 dans les
bourgs ruraux ont des nombres 1,2 vols
de véhicule pour 1000 habitants un taux
qui va jusqu'à 3 dans les grandes villes
en revanche il y a certaines infractions
où la délinquance rurale se rapproche de
la délinquance dans les grands centres
urbains et notamment pour les violences
sexuelles dans l'espace rural en 2022 on
est aux alentours d'une affaire de
violences sexuelles pour 1000 habitants
ses proches du taux de violence sexuelle
des grands centres urbains qui est à 1,4
si on prend également les violences
intra-familial et notamment les coûts et
blessures dans les bourreaux le taux est
de 2 cas de violences intrafamiliales
pour 1000 habitants il est à trois dans
les grands centres urbains en revanche
et bien il y a des délits où les carrés
est très fort entre le rural et l'urbain
notamment les viols sont les vols sont
violences avec personne comme les
pickpockets en 2022 on est à 4 volts de
ce type en zone rurale contre pour 1000
habitants contre un taux de 17 vols pour
1000 habitants dans les grands centres
urbains forcément les big pocket se
développent dans les grandes villes donc
on voit que la délinquance rurale est
forte pour certains délits et plus
faible pour d'autres merci Alex
Marie-Laure présent on a vu les chiffres
est-ce que la délinquance en milieu
rural est une délinquance qui a tendance
à s'accroître
alors on a au niveau de la gendarmerie
on a
96% du territoire donc sur ce découpage
c'est un peu complexe de vraiment
opposer le rural à l'urbain puisqu'on a
aussi des zones périurbaines donc on
nous on a une on a les chiffres qui
viennent d'être présentés on a certains
types de délinquance qui sont peut-être
un peu plus spécifiques au milieu rural
mais on a aussi des nouvelles formes de
délinquance qui apparaissent on a
récemment fait un point par exemple sur
les atteintes ou bien dans le monde
agricole puisqu'effectivement il y a par
exemple des vols de GPS un certain
nombre de phénomènes qui peuvent
ponctuellement
faire jour on a la cyber sécurité aussi
qui est de plus en plus prégnante et là
finalement il y a pas de frontière entre
l'urbain et le rural donc c'est de la
délinquance
contre laquelle on lutte et pour les
pour laquelle en fait on accroie aussi
notre prévention pour sensibiliser
l'ensemble du territoire on va revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit c'est
intéressant notamment
spécificité pardon de la délinquance
rurale vous constatez vous Stéphane
sotarel qui est élu du Cantal donc
évidemment qui est au cœur de tout ça
vous vous constatez une augmentation de
cette délinquance rurale et des
spécificités liées à l'ère ruralité je
sais pas s'ils sont les spécificités
mais on constate à la fois une
augmentation de la délinquance et aussi
une augmentation du sentiment
d'insécurité qui sont parfois pas
exactement les mêmes choses mais mais
qui correspondent quand même à une
réalité on a un constat assez clair par
exemple dans un département comme le
Cantal d'une augmentation de de
l'attaque ou en tout cas des violences
ou des atteintes à l'intégrité physique
des personnes comme vous venez de le
souligner qui est en augmentation mais
également face aux
biens des personnes qui qui avec les
vols avec un certain nombre de
délinquance de ce type là et puis un
phénomène qu'on n'a pas dont on n'a pas
encore parlé qui qui semble apparaître
de façon forte en réalité la réalité
n'est pas éloignée des de trafic de
stupéfiants et de consommation de
stupéfiants et donc d'addiction ou de
difficultés liées aux stupéfiants par
exemple le colonel de gendarmerie
récemment me disait qu'aujourd'hui dans
les contrôles sur la sécurité routière
il y a autant de positifs aux
stupéfiants qu'à l'alcool ce qui est
quand même un phénomène nouveau et
particulièrement inquiétant dans des
territoires comme les notes on pensait
un peu plus éloigné de ce de cette
question là et aujourd'hui il n'en est
rien donc le fait qu'il y ait besoin
d'apporter un service de proximité pour
répondre à la fois au sentiment de la
sécurité mais aussi à la réalité
d'insécurité aussi bien du côté de la
gendarmerie qu'en zone de police parce
qu'on a malgré tout dans nos territoires
ruraux aussi des petites villes des
villes moyennes qui sont en zone de
police et donc ça c'est un besoin qui
effectivement aujourd'hui est important
cette spécificité vous nous l'avez un
peu dit Marie-Laure paysan il y a
quelque part des spécificités liées à la
ruralité notamment vous nous avez un
petit peu parlé d'agriculture est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur ce en quoi ça consiste
précisément alors concernant les
atteintes au monde agricole nous avons
en zone rurale des exploitations
agricoles effectivement qu'on trouve pas
en zone urbaine donc ça entraîne un
certain nombre de spécificités de la
délinquance d'appropriation on a 93% des
atteintes qui sont portés au monde
agricole qui sont des atteintes au bien
donc ça va être des vols simples
majoritairement ça va être des
dégradations des destructions de bien
d'engins de matériel et beaucoup de
beaucoup de vols au quotidien donc on a
cette particularité des vols de GPS
c'est-à-dire alors les GPS agricoles ce
sont des donc les les exploitants pour
pouvoir
améliorer leur leur cadence
d'exploitation mais aussi finalement
utiliser la juste semence ne pas gâcher
de produits etc ils utilisent des GPS
agricoles qui leur permettent de par
exemple semer
de manière extrêmement précise euh sur
leur territoire et donc ça leur permet
aussi de gagner du temps de se
concentrer sur d'autres tâches CGPS du
coup sont très importants pour pour eux
pour leur exploitation et ce sont des
des c'est du matériel qui peut coûter
jusqu'à 10 ou 15000 € donc c'est très
coûteux et c'est il y a régulièrement
des vols de GPS qui sont récupérés qui
peuvent être emmenés notamment dans les
pays de l'Est et donc ça c'est une
particularité du monde agricole après
pour revenir sur le sujet des
stupéfiants on a je serai un peu plus
mesuré parce que on a une combinaison de
choses on a effectivement des
stupéfiants dans les dans les zones plus
rurales mais j'ai envie de dire c'est
pas forcément un phénomène nouveau par
contre on a une évolution du trafic on
assiste maintenant à des cultures on a
plus on découvre plus de culture indoor
on a du stockage qui peut se faire dans
les zones rurales et on a aussi accéléré
nos contrôles de sur les routes puisque
le stupéfiant passe nécessairement par
la route donc il est important pour nous
d'augmenter les contrôles et on en a les
moyens maintenant donc on constate cette
augmentation aussi on va parler de ces
fameuses brigades de gendarmerie en
réalité puis qui ont été imaginés pour
renforcer la lutte contre la délinquance
en milieu rural la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur déjà votée
par le Parlement prévoit donc la
création de 200 nouvelles brigades d'une
implantation qui se fait en concertation
avec les élus locaux on va en parler
avec vous plusieurs communes aux
candidatées pour accueillir ces brigades
Flora sauvages s'est rendu dans l'une
d'entre elles boîte sénée s'est en
Vendée regarde
200 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
doivent voir le jour dans les cinq ans à
venir en Vendée bois de Séné s'est porté
candidate une commune de 2000 habitants
à 50 minutes au sud de Nantes qui attire
de plus en plus la démographie sur le
territoire elle est forte depuis on va
dire l'après covid il y a eu un fort
changement de la population on a une un
effet de masse qui apparaît et au niveau
de la sécurité on se retrouve aussi des
stabilisés les infractions sur le col de
code de la route les personnes se
veulent aller de plus en plus vite sur
leur lieu de travail leur domicile et
ainsi de suite nous avons aussi les
cambriolages qui est fortement présent
aussi sur nos territoires les
stupéfiants actuellement la brigade de
gendarmerie la plus proche est basée sur
la commune de Challans mais elle couvre
un territoire étendu si vous avez un
véhicule de gendarmerie qui est à
l'extrémité de Palio et qui doit
intervenir soit sur bois de Séné ou sur
bois il leur faudra trois quarts d'heure
de route pour le président de la de
communes la création de trois brigades
de gendarmerie en Vendée permettra de
mieux gérer les actes de délinquance
dans le département
la candidature de bois de Séné qui se
positionne sur le nord de Chalon
vis-à-vis d'un bassin de délinquance
qu'on voit arriver le long des axes
routiers plutôt de la Loire-Atlantique
de la région nantaise et qui arrive sur
le territoire de Challans et au-delà par
cet axe là et donc ça nous paraissait
pertinent d'avoir une implantation de
gendarmerie à la rencontre des éventuels
flux que nous constatons de savoir si la
candidature de bois de Séné va être
retenue Magalie accueille d'un bon œil
l'arrivée des futurs militaires moi
j'habite sur la commune depuis 12 ans il
y a aussi il y a un sentiment
d'insécurité la nuit il y a eu des
cambriolages tout ça enfin on sent qu'il
y a besoin ouais de plus de sécurité en
fait il y a aussi tout ce qui est drogue
et tout ça aussi on sent que ça circule
quand même et du coup moi j'ai des ados
et j'ai envie de les protéger mes ados
pour accueillir la future brigade le
maire a déjà repéré deux terrains si sa
commune est sélectionnée il aura 5 ans
pour construire des logements pour les
15 militaires et leurs familles coût
estimés 4,5 millions d'euros financés en
grande partie par l'État
Stéphane sotorel est-ce que le renfort
de ces deux sambrigades dans une rural
c'est la bonne réponse c'est une réponse
en tout cas on peut se réjouir de de
cette annonce on est impatient nous
aussi sur le territoire du Cantal de
connaître les décisions et les choix qui
ont été faits on a pu dans un dialogue
local faire remonter des besoins de nos
territoire un peu similaire à ceux qui
viennent d'être évoqués des besoins de
proximité effectivement donc il y a deux
candidatures de brigade qui ont été
remontées pour ce qui concerne le Cantal
une plutôt en périphérie de la zone
agglomérée d'Aurillac donc sur le
secteur nord de d'Aurillac sur l'ouest
du département avec un besoin et une
spécificité cynophile aussi parce que
c'est un besoin particulier pour
répondre à certaines recherches et à
certaines délinquance avec en plus une
zone de montagne chez nous qui a aussi
besoin pour des questions de sauvetage
en montagne de ce type de
d'intervention avec des chiens en plus
de des autres spécificités et puis sur
l'est du du comportement la plutôt une
brigade mobile en lien avec un axe
autoroutier et de manière complémentaire
avec le secteur de Saint-Flour sur la
commune nouvelle de valdercommy un
projet aussi dont on espère qu'il pourra
améliorer la couverture en fait moi je
parle de maillage du territoire ce qui
est important pour la gendarmerie c'est
une grande proximité avec les habitants
donc un bon maillage une présence par
exemple ou c'est une présence ponctuelle
quand il y a des des jours avec des
manifestations des marchés dans
certaines communes rurales il est
important d'être présent plus fortement
ce jour-là et donc ce qui compte c'est
ce maillage qui avait été un peu mis à
mal par le passé et qui j'espère
aujourd'hui va pouvoir être renforcé par
ces 200 brigades qui viendront en
complément aussi de déjà d'un renfort
qu'on a eu sur le secteur de Mauriac
dans le département du Cantal avec un
polton de surveillance et
d'investigation de gendarmerie un PSIG
qui vient de voir le jour vient d'être
installé sur le secteur de Mauriac on en
manquait cruellement sur toute une
partie de notre de notre département
voilà donc c'est peut-être pas la
réponse mais mais mais c'est sans doute
un des éléments de réponse et on va
parler de ce maillage territorial dans
quelques instants mais on va aller
voir rejoindre bonjour Monsieur le Maire
maire de Dompierre-sur-Mer c'est en
Charente-Maritime vous avez candidaté
vous pour accueillir ces brigades de
gendarmerie pourquoi
oui bonjour à toutes et bonjour à tous
bah écoutez je me retrouve complètement
dans les propos qui viennent être tenus
par mon collègue de Vendée donc hier sur
mer est une commune de l'agglomération
de La Rochelle donc en zone périurbaine
et connaît une augmentation de sa
population comme une grande partie des
communes de l'agglomération de La
Rochelle et donc et du coup les communes
que nous sommes
connaissent les problèmes de la ville
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on importe
aussi chez nous les problèmes de des
zones urbaines donc quand on cumule
l'augmentation de notre population et
l'importation de ces problèmes et bien
il est nécessaire de de trouver des
solutions pour renforcer les les forces
de sécurité sur nos communes et
aujourd'hui il était nécessaire sur
l'agglomération de La Rochelle d'avoir
se redécoupage de la zone de gendarmerie
qui propose donc une zone nouvelle
caserne sur l'est de l'agglomération de
La Rochelle et après échange et c'est
important de le dire aussi c'est un
travail qui a été mené avec le
groupement de gendarmerie de la
Charente-Maritime c'est la commune de
Dompierre-sur-Mer qui a été choisie pour
des questions
pratiques des questions d'organisation
technique
on a un petit problème de liaison à
Guillaume Cabal on va vous retrouver
très vite on a vu deux exemples de
communes candidates notre reportage a
aboie de Séné en Vendée Guillaume crabal
lui pour la Charente-Maritime comment
vont être départagés ces communes
candidates Marie-Laure prison alors
actuellement on a encore des projets qui
remontent le ministre a annoncé
effectivement 200 brigades sur
l'ensemble du territoire ça fait à peu
près 2 à 4 brigades ça peut être parfois
un peu plus par département là pour
l'instant il y a trois critères qui sont
importants c'est déjà la faisabilité la
rapidité de mise en oeuvre du projet
parce que si on veut qu'elles arrivent
vite il faut pas que ce soit dans 10 ans
elles arrivent quand elles seront elles
seront mises en place première
arriveront d'ici la fin de l'année d'ici
la fin de l'année parce qu'on a deux
types de brigades ça je pourrais revenir
dessus mais du coup les premières
arriveront d'ici la fin de l'année donc
on a la rapidité pardon rapidité de mise
en œuvre il y a la faisabilité technique
savoir si on a déjà une emprise un local
pour accueillir les gendarmes
éventuellement des logements savoir si
on est prêt d'un axe routier voilà s'il
y a aussi la possibilité de mettre
rapidement du matériel technique et on a
aussi l'opportunité de créer une unité
est-ce qu'il y a un besoin particulier à
un endroit est-ce qu'il y a un besoin de
proximité est-ce qu'il y a une
augmentation de la population la
gendarmerie depuis 10 ans a pris 2
millions d'habitants supplémentaires et
l'Insee annonce d'ici 2027 un million
d'habitants supplémentaires donc on va
fatalement avoir des endroits où on a
une augmentation de population et c'est
peut-être là aussi où il y a des besoins
donc ces trois critères là vont faire
partie des critères étudiés et vont
permettre de définir les endroits les
plus pertinents pour créer des unités le
ministre fera des annonces autour du
mois de juin pour qu'on puisse
identifier les emprises qui seront
retenues bon vous nous dites il y a
encore des projets qui remontent est-ce
que vous savez à peu près combien de
projets sont arrivés au ministère j'ai
pas non j'ai pas le chiffre je sais
qu'il y a plus de 200 projets bien sûr
il y a toujours
donc il faudra un choix effectivement
c'est ce qui est ce qui est bien aussi
dans le dispositif c'est que tout le
monde c'est c'est il y a eu un
engouement pour ce projet on a eu
beaucoup de propositions une
concertation très efficace localement
les élus ont joué le jeu et donc c'est
vrai qu'on a beaucoup de projets qui
sont remontés
de de gendarmes et de sécurité et donc
par les temps qui courent je crois que
c'est une bonne une bonne nouvelle et
effectivement moi je rebondis sur ce que
venait d'indiquer sur sur la volonté le
partage avec le groupement de
gendarmerie et avec la volonté des élus
locaux et donc par exemple sur la
périphérie de de d'Aurillac en zone
périurbaine où il y a une augmentation
de la population la commune de Jussac en
l'occurrence c'est positionné un
apportant du foncier puisque c'est la
commune qui apporte le terrain sur
laquelle la caserne peut être construite
avec donc cette volonté d'identifier et
de permettre très rapidement une
opération qui peut être montée avec
notamment les bailleurs sociaux
qui s'engagent aussi pour construire
rapidement ces brigades et les rendre
vite opérationnelles donc on est tout à
fait dans dans cette dynamique là comme
sur les autres communes dont on a pu
entendre des témoignages on va retourner
en Charente-Maritime retrouver Guillaume
grabel Guillaume krabel vous l'avez
entendu il y a des choix qui vont être
faits est-ce que vous êtes optimiste sur
le fait que votre commune soit retenue
toujours optimiste après comme ça a été
indiqué je pense qu'il y aura plus de
400 dossiers sur les 200 casernes
possibles nous avons fait le meilleur
dossier avec l'agglomération de La
Rochelle qui correspond surtout à des
besoins sur le territoire et et donc on
croise les doigts et on espère que le
dossier sera retenu donc si j'ai bien
compris pour en juin
on peut parler de ce maillage
territorial Stéphane sotarel en parler
il y a 224 000 policiers nationaux et
gendarmes qui maillent le territoire
est-ce qu'il y a des inégalités
territoriales Marie-Laure pesant et si
oui comment les explique
alors au niveau de la gendarmerie nous
on a 3100 brigades territoriales donc on
a déjà un maillage très fort sur
l'ensemble du territoire l'objectif
c'est d'apporter le même service public
à toute la population à toutes les
communes donc on est dans cette logique
là d'être vraiment égalité sur le
service rendu mais est-ce que c'est le
cas est-ce qu'il y a des déserts
sécuritaires comme on veut des déserts
médicaux il y a pas de désert sécurité
en tout cas en zone gendarmerie on n'a
pas des heures sécuritaire on a des
unités qui sont peut-être parfois plus
éloignées mais pour autant on a des
patrouilles qui circulent sur ces
territoires et donc on a une présence de
la gendarmerie pour autant on se rend
compte qu'il y a peut-être certains
territoires qui sont peut-être très
étendus on aurait besoin de de ramener
de la proximité c'est d'ailleurs une
attente de la population avoir plus de
proximité et on est aussi dans une
logique d'aller vers aller vers donc on
a des moyens technologiques maintenant
qui nous permettent aussi d'aller comme
dit notre directeur général on passe
d'une logique de guichet une logique de
pas de porte et donc on va au plus près
de la population pour prendre une
plainte donc on a maintenant des
ordinateurs qu'on appelle ubiquity qui
nous permettent en fait de prendre une
plainte sur le terrain donc voilà tous
ces outils nous permettent maintenant de
nous rapprocher de la population et donc
la création de ces nouvelles unités qui
seront donc soit fixes soit mobile parce
que on a deux types de brigades la
brigade avec une emprise qui va avoir
son propre territoire les gendarmes qui
vont travailler sur ce territoire et
quelque part ces unités fixes vont
soulager une autre unité qui avait
peut-être un territoire un peu grand et
on a les brigades mobiles qui elles vont
partir d'unité fixe et qui vont ensuite
se déplacer sur le territoire aller
faire des permanences dans les mairies
dans des locaux qui seront mis à
disposition dans des espaces services
donc on a des logiques différentes aussi
qui vont être mises en oeuvre en
fonction des besoins identifiés et ça
dans les deux dans les deux sens pardon
nouvelle brigades ça se répartit comment
alors ben pour l'instant tout dépend des
projets qui sont remontés mais je sais
que dans tous les territoires vous avez
à la fois des projets de brigade fixes
qui ont été proposés et des projets de
brigades mobiles parfois les brigades
fils d'ailleurs comme disait monsieur le
sénateur peuvent aussi avoir une
dimension équipe cynophile ou une
brigade équestre qui va pouvoir
renforcer sur un domaine particulier la
brigade déjà existante
j'ajouterai un point complémentaire
effectivement assez deux types de
brigades il y a aussi le brigades
spécialisées sur lesquelles aujourd'hui
nous essayons de plaider pour lesquels
nous essayons de plaider par exemple
dans un département rural il y a des
enjeux particuliers liés à la ruralité
ou liés à l'agriculture et donc sur la
police de l'environnement ou sur
d'autres phénomènes comme ceux qui ont
été évoqués tout à l'heure sur
l'agriculture parce que au-delà des vols
de matériaux ou de
carburant qui existent sur les chantiers
comme dans l'agriculture il y a
aujourd'hui aussi des incivilités ou des
actions militantes qui posent atteintes
qui portent atteinte au bien particulier
des agriculteurs et donc il est
important d'avoir aussi des actions
spécialisées dans ce domaine là comme
dans le secteur de l'environnement et
par exemple pour ce qui est du
département du Cantal nous souhaitons
aussi reconvertir une brigade en la
densifiant parce qu'il est important
qu'une brigade est un effectif suffisant
par exemple dans le projet de 200
brigades aujourd'hui on est sur des
projets avec un minimum de 10 gendarmes
par brigade de façon à assurer une bonne
continuité une bonne présence ça c'est
une difficulté parce qu'il ne suffit pas
d'avoir une implantation mais il faut
aussi avoir des effectifs suffisants par
brigade et on va y venir sur la question
des effectifs mais Guillaume crabal
brigade chips mobile pour vous
c'est une brigade fixe avec une
possibilité d'avoir 15 gendarmes
sachant qu'aujourd'hui la zone de
Dompierre-sur-Mer dans laquelle pour
laquelle
nous postulons c'est 23 gendarmes donc
on vient rajouter 15 gendarmes sur le
territoire en haut découpant les zones
et donc c'est l'arrivée effectivement du
service public de proximité sur notre
notre terrain et c'est effectivement ce
qu'il manque aujourd'hui et c'est
renforcer aussi la présence du service
public et c'est ce sentiment d'abandon
qu'on vient combattre aussi aujourd'hui
en proposant ces effectifs
supplémentaires sur notre terrain il y
avait aussi des délais d'intervention
qui étaient longs chez vous on a entendu
à bois de Séné des délais d'intervention
qui pouvaient aller jusqu'à trois quart
d'heure chez vous c'est c'était le cas
ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un jardin pour
1500 habitants sur un territoire qui
fait 10 communes alors que le ratio pour
un travail efficace d'un gendarme et
d'un gendarme pour 1000 habitants donc
on va renforcer la présence de les
effectifs de gendarmerie et diminuer les
temps d'intervention donc c'est c'est
excellent à la fois pour la qualité
d'intervention de la gendarmerie qui
fait de l'excellent travail et qui des
fois
est empêché en raison de ces distances
d'interventions et on vient renforcer
les effectifs sur des territoires qui en
manquent je vais laisser répondre
Marie-Laure plaisant à ce que vous venez
de dire il y a des fois des un an une
forme d'empêchement liés à ces délais
d'intervention à ces distances trop
longues dans ces zones rurales alors ce
qui se passe c'est que on a parfois des
territoires effectivement qui sont un
peu vastes et on a tendance à avoir une
surveillance plus particulière sur les
zones où on identifie de la délinquance
où on sait que potentiellement il peut y
avoir de la délinquance et donc à faire
des patrouilles de prévention sur les
secteurs qui peuvent être parfois plus
plus touchés par certains phénomènes
donc c'est vrai que quand on est
beaucoup sur certains territoires et ben
peut-être que parfois on délaisse
certains autres territoires et le jour
où il se passe quelque chose sur ces
autres territoires mais nos délais
d'intervention peuvent être un peu longs
donc c'est vrai que cette nouvelle c'est
nouvelle brigade vont permettre
finalement de renforcer cette proximité
et de réduire mécaniquement les délais
d'intervention effectivement ils avaient
aussi une réponse à une demande de la
population Stéphane sotarel c'est 200
brigades sa réponse aussi à une volonté
de la population de se sentir mieux
protégé
tout à l'heure le sentiment d'insécurité
mais qui est parfois aussi vécu qui est
aussi une réalité et donc il y a une
attente il y a une demande de la
population ça a été dit par chacun des
des mers qui sont intervenus et donc il
y a ce besoin de répondre à cette
reconnaissance aussi du milieu du milieu
rural vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
notion de désert en faisant un parallèle
entre désert médicaux et des heures
sécurité effectivement moi je confirme
qu'il y a pas de désert de sécurité en
revanche il y a des besoins
complémentaires et notamment en prenant
en compte aussi le territoire et pas
seulement la population parce qu'on l'a
dit les temps d'intervention sont
importants et même si le territoire est
moins dense il y a des besoins de
renforcement et ce sont les trois
premiers services publics qui sont
attendus par la population la sécurité
l'éducation et la santé quand on ne
répond pas à ces trois services de base
essentiel on ne peut pas prétendre
prendre en compte les besoins de la
population et donc c'est pourquoi je me
réjouis pour l'instant de ce qui est une
annonce et et qu'on nourrit beaucoup
d'espoir sur les réponses qui sont
apportées quant à ces 200 brigades parce
que ça correspond vraiment à une attente
et ce sera un signe positif on n'a pas
de temps de signe positif que ça en
direction de la ruralité avec des
renforcements de moyens et des services
publics là on aurait un vrai signe
positif un vrai message en direction de
la réalité Guillaume ça correspond aussi
à une demande de votre population vos
administrés vous vous ont fait part de
leur volonté de voir cette grillade
créer dans votre commune
alors je bien entendu ce serait un plus
pour la sécurité de nos habitants de mes
habitants cela dit je fondais un peu on
a la chance de vivre dans des communes
qui ne connaissent pas de grandes
délinquance donc par contre
on a une augmentation comme ça a été dit
en introduction du nombre de
cambriolages on a une augmentation des
insécurités d'insécurité routière le vol
du GPS est parti aussi de notre
quotidien et donc l'arrivée de ces
nouveaux gendarmes via répondre à un
besoin de la population et je j'appuie
avec l'agglomération de La Rochelle pour
que le dossier puisse être entendu donc
par le ministère de l'Intérieur
il y a aussi vous aussi vous il vous est
remonté ce sentiment d'abandon d'une
partie de la population Marie la
représente on a cette demande de
proximité ça c'est c'est vrai que on a
la population qui demande à ce qu'on
aille au contact et finalement on parle
souvent d'intervention mais la
gendarmerie c'est pas que ça c'est
l'intervention mais c'est aussi de la
prévention c'est du contact avec la
population pour
recueillir du renseignement savoir quels
sont les problématiques
identifiées orienter ses patrouilles
donc ça c'est important et il y a tout
toute la dimension judiciaire aussi
d'enquête donc en fait tout ça tous ces
éléments là doivent être pris en compte
et en étant en proximité on pourra aussi
davantage faire de la prévention et
avoir du renseignement pour l'ensemble
des autres missions on parlait tout à
l'heure de Stéphane sotarel pas pointé
la question des effectifs ils seront là
c'est ces effectifs il y a pas de
problème de recrutement il y aura pas de
problème pour justement que les
gendarmes en plus puisque ce sont des
gendarmes en plus dans ces brigades de
gendarmerie soient bien là alors dans le
cadre de la loopy on a des effectifs en
plus qui qui seront là donc on a plus de
2000 gendarmes c'est un gain net qui
sera qui sera fait c'est en plus de
l'existant on aura à terme 2000
effectifs de plus donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez historique assez
nouveau et on s'en réjouit au niveau de
la gendarmerie mais je pense au niveau
des élus de la population c'est vraiment
un plus on on a aussi une campagne de
recrutement que vous avez peut-être déjà
aperçu là elle parle avec la flamme
donc c'est vrai que cette campagne là
est là aussi pour des seins de recruter
12000 personnes pour 2023 c'est
l'objectif donc on est vraiment dans un
renouvellement permanent nos effectifs
mais avec en plus des effectifs
supplémentaires on aura effectivement
des gendarmes quand les brigades seront
mises en place on va avoir un calendrier
politique qui va être annoncé avec cette
mise en place le calendrier RH suivra et
donc on a l'objectif de créer des unités
mixtes avec à la fois des gendarmes qui
sont expérimentés et qui ont déjà une
connaissance de la gendarmerie des
procédures et du terrain avec des
gendarmes qui vont sortir d'école
puisque comme je vous ai dit on a dix
mille gendarmes de paiement qui sont en
train d'être recrutés formés et donc ils
armeront également ces unités la
conclusion Stéphane sauvage oui je
partage cette idée que la présence
visible est un élément important en
termes de prévention et pour également
rassurer la population même si nous ne
sommes pas dans des zones où la
délinquance et la plus forte dans notre
pays est fort heureusement mais il faut
justement garder cet avantage
concurrentiel du bien vivre sur nos
territoires et donc rassurer avec cette
présence de gendarmes au quotidien sur
nos territoires voilà essentiel un
dernier mois les 20 secondes pour faire
la promotion de la candidature de
Dompierre-sur-Mer
c'est le moment mais écoutez comme ça a
été il y a plusieurs reprises on a
besoin absolument en tant que mère de ce
maillage de notre territoire par des
forces de sécurité avec notre police
municipale et le maire ne peut rien sans
il est le pivot de toutes ces forces de
sécurité et donc il faut qu'il puisse
travailler avec eux faut qu'elle soit en
plus grand nombre et donc
l'apport de cette de ces nouveaux
effectifs est un plus à la fois pour
l'action du maire mais pour toute la
population de nos de nos communes voilà
et ce sera le mot de la fin merci à tous
les trois pour ce débat si vous voulez
bien rester avec nous on va regarder ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
et Alex dans la presse régionale
aujourd'hui on parle des commémorations
de la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et oui l'hommage et la transmission à la
Une de La Voix du Nord aujourd'hui une
voix du nord consacrée au commémorations
hier de la victoire du 8 mai 1945 la
victoire des Alliés face à l'Allemagne
nazie l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est bien la
transmission de la mémoire collective
alors que les anciens combattants
disparaissent peu à peu dans le
Pas-de-Calais par exemple l'Union
Départementale des combattants
organisent des formations pour les
jeunes dès 14 ans pour qu'il puisse
participer à ces cérémonies et un
responsable de cette association
témoigne il le dit un les jeunes sont
plutôt intéressés par la guerre et ils
nous demandent comment on se battait
exactement à l'époque et ils sont
intéressés par ce sujet notamment depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine et
justement cette commération de la
victoire sur l'Allemagne nazie s'invite
aussi dans le conflit en Ukraine c'est à
la une du Télégramme une victoire qui
est célébrée en Russie le 9 mai
aujourd'hui avec de traditionnels
célébrations à Moscou sur la Place Rouge
et l'Ukraine a décidé cette année de ne
pas célébrer cette victoire le 9 mai
comme l'ennemirus mais le 8 mai hier le
président
ukrainien volo des meilleurs zenenski
qui adore d'ailleurs fait un discours et
affirmer que le mal que représentait la
Russie moderne aujourd'hui serait vaincu
comme elle a été le nazisme hier la
crise du logement une de plusieurs
quotidiens régionaux de Nord-Éclair et
du journal Sud-Ouest il est aujourd'hui
très compliqué de trouver un bien à
louer l'offre locative diminue il est
également difficile d'obtenir un prêt
immobilier les taux d'intérêts ont
grimpé et la France compte aujourd'hui 4
millions de mal logés et dans ce
contexte de crise du logement et bien le
Conseil national de la refondation sur
le logement va remettre ses propositions
aujourd'hui parmi elles de nouvelles
aides fiscales pour favoriser la
construction un meilleur accompagnement
des plus vulnérables et puis impossible
encadrement des prix du foncier sur le
monde sur le modèle de l'encadrement des
loyers dans certaines métropoles sur ce
sujet du logement il y a une ville qui
est observée de près par l'État c'est
Marseille selon le journal La
Marseillaise la municipalité ne
respecterait pas ses objectifs fixés par
la loi en matière de construction de
logements sociaux il faut avoir 25% de
logements sociaux sur son territoire
c'est la loi et Serru et un courrier du
préfet que c'est procuré le journal La
Marseillaise affirme que la ville n'a
atteint qu'un tiers de ces objectifs
donc elle encourt de possibles sanctions
qui pourraient aller jusqu'à une reprise
en main par l'état des permis de
construire dans la cité phocéenne allez
il nous reste un 10 secondes pour parler
de Jean-Michel Lelas claque claque de
fin pour Jean-Michel Aulas puisque le
nouveau propriétaire américain de
l'Olympique Lyonnais après la présidence
du club plus vite que prévu et à
remercier Jean-Michel Aulas qui est bien
mais un terme à une aventure de plus de
36 ans à la tête de l'Olympique Lyonnais
merci beaucoup
Alex merci pour cette revue de presse
merci Stéphane sotorel merci Marie-Laure
présente qui est juste derrière et
conversible d'avoir participé à ce débat
si vous voulez voir ou revoir cette
émission notre nouvelle plateforme
public sénat.fr à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas et nous on se
retrouve demain très bonne journée
[Musique]